Shh how's it going bros my name is Peter
pip pip haha
beautiful all right breasts so it would
seem that we are nearing the end of the
game it might actually happen in this
very episode I really don't know how
much but it looks like it's time to
finally confront Gary and if anyone
remembers Gary he's like like that guy
Gary Gary Oaks you know that
[ __ ] for keeps
and every time I choose the leaf Pokemon
a [ __ ] chooses the fire pokemon and
every time I should fire pokemon a
[ __ ] chooses the water pokemon and
every time I fight does it make sense
alright we're going over here it's gotta
be awesome that's all you need to know
okay what's up girl
oh yeah hell are you doing here looking
for you Zoe I think I'm in love
don't be ridiculous fighting each other
that was awesome oh man I gotta go
how am I gonna deal with this I'm such a
serious backup yeah where's Russell
where's your buddy Edgar Russell has
been holed up in the Wonder meat
slaughterhouse hiding from the cops
prison after stealing that by Russell
Carrasco prison Wow
look I'll see you later a lot of
progress what about love you don't have
to wait Zoe duty calls
everyone is so good at acting in this
game so sad I'm so sad by this alright
so we just got to go over here I don't
know why tells me to go over here I
thought we're gonna go back to school
Oh a bike that's more my no Michael
beside how you say it in Spanish
let's take the jump road you're us ready
for this oh you broke mad about
are you ready for that Wow oh we got to
say Brussels that's it how do we get
inside there it is Russell what are you
doing the problems of life when you
don't know what today go Russell they
don't even care what do they care about
me and that Russell neighbor after him
go Russell Russell go Roger Roger watch
with your nipple a tree yeah I didn't
count to three though you're welcome bro
you're welcome my bruschetta
hey Jim this is your turf what the
hell's going on the whole place is gone
mental yeah it's your old friend Gary
he's the one causing all the trouble
the kids a complete psycho and now he's
got the teachers and prefix on his side
so so we run in there try to stop the
fighting and find a way to deal with
Gary alright why I wasn't laughs by
looking at your stop a load of kids from
beating the crap out of each other it's
America you just moved that with threats
and bribes until we get what we want if
[ __ ] yeah Mary got crap out of everyone
that's why I brought along backup Rosa
listen likes to hurt people for peace
that is so inspirational then it's a
plan for peace I want a pirate that's a
paradox we need
Russell is amazing we'll take out the
gang leaders Gary's got nothing
Laura are you okay Russell are you okay
my friend all right we gotta beat their
asses the problem is my health right now
I wish I had a little more help
let's get the gold card and [ __ ] people
up [ __ ] [ __ ] let's do this Russell
for Sparta I made Russell okay let's
start with the ladies you know we love
the ladies all that ain't nothing baby
all right come on where the [ __ ] do I go
hello I'll be exited everyone exits
their cars like that what is he doing
he's not doing anything what the hell
are you doing Johnny
yeah are you taking orders from Gary
shut up Jimmy you left us and everything
went down the toilet I beat you once
I'll beat you again
that's right
you are going on below lowlights a slot
stop trying to be with that girl rasa
come on man I thought you were better
than that why isn't he dead yet
Russell smash hahahaha there we go
alright more people to kill fine with me
absolutely splendid what's next Russell
well Russell you're crazy man he jumps
over me ah ah nerd sauce nice house man
nerds are going down this should be
easiest one oh it's a oh [ __ ] it's a
jocks hey I need you to help me get lost
Jimmy you ain't enough you're just
asking for it
I said they got baseball bat [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] Ted is like the weakest character
ever I didn't realize it when I was
playing but it's like a suppose a pocket
like at a shed you can't do anything
then you saw it there we go
that's that [ __ ] who's next
Russell don't have a lot of health what
what's going on with an angle what the
[ __ ] why am I looking at Jimmy's but
what happen here what the [ __ ] oh there
we go
what the [ __ ] what's that and we're
going to the gym next though I know the
scholars or whatever the [ __ ] they are
what what whatta [ __ ] Russell abandon
ship
no my precious gold card anything
goodbye precious go cut I saw something
here firecrackers I guess it could help
alright next one
oh it's the thud don't worry boys I'll
deal with him come on you guys suck you
can't beat me in Russell
don't you dare spill a drop of five
that's right Russell destroy die a
little batch
there we go check up all right the last
faction leader and then we're done yay
yay yay it's probably Gary or the Nerds
that my poor go-kart Betsy what do they
do to you come on Ben come on goddamn it
this is really it's the final end huh
my precious go-kart might as well take
this yeah no you know no you don't need
that [ __ ] I know the mascot I love
the dance they're [ __ ] out of their
mind all of them second time they burn
the gym - why is that waiting three
clocks watch
this is Chad kiss
fatality can't press super effective
if I had known Spray pens was so good I
want to use it more meet Edgar and here
we are let's meet with gotta let key ed
get go as I like to call em a bunch of
[ __ ] you burned your benches yeah
that's what he said
everyone calm down some business
understood
good luck we literally haven't seen Gary
until chapter 1 it's crazy what no Roy I
love Russell he's like the best
character ever really your attention
please
Jimmy's complete humans oh it's a boss
battle time Gary you little [ __ ]
yeah James I've been waiting let the
games begin
oh so they took my weapons now I think
so I can't use them against Gary that
kind of sucks but hey what can you do
your tie dad it's handing out are you
guys
oh it's Gary yeah I won I tricked
everyone starting with you the head the
loser kids in town and the prefix me I
won huge um yeah man I might be sad but
I've run your world [ __ ] and don't you
forget it you did all my dirty work for
me Hopkins you're like a puppet
Oh No whatever let's finish this our
final battle again hey what the [ __ ] I
don't have any weapons yeah
all right whoa
it's throwing [ __ ] at me it's not fair
I'm a [ __ ] sag well I would this is
dangerous
you can kill him you can tell me Gary
Gary don't you dare tell me I'll kill
you if you prove to be one thing this
year it's smaller don't never catch me
Hopkins you're too trusting Jimmy from
the start you were pathetically naive
what ah look at this purse Chappell
Jimmy wait oh wait wait
drama bear Jimmy Joe oh wait wait ha
aah Jimmy Oh big scary board under not
come up hey we just meant again and
you're [ __ ] crazy but I'm falling down
the head thing why do I sing that song
anymore
I told you to give it up what are you
doin why did you jump is that oh oh come
on honey
[ __ ] why'd you do it Gary hey Gary Mora
I didn't noted that all right I got it
does again I'll say in a second Jimmy
Shambu Jimmy wait wait again hahaha god
damn you talk elijah's yeah it's a
really interesting character too though
it's a shame we didn't see more of him
honestly
all right the battle begins here I would
have said it's crazy what okay I get it
Gary you were smart and planned it all
if I win you're just another Punk you
win and you'll be sent away even quicker
for beating up the head boy why'd you do
it Gary yeah I can because making little
people like you and the morons who run
this place eat out of the palm of my
hand feels right I never did anything to
you
you wanted the shit's I'd given you the
chance face it I'm slower than you mine
than me you ain't everyone and everyone
hates you Jeanne the head likes me I
tied him up turned his dog's gone to a
battleground guys kids expelled unfairly
put several others into therapy and they
still likes me
okay go sir not well at least my mom
doesn't make her living on her back oh
no you didn't say that about my mama are
you doing I pushed you down oh I'll
fight I'll back up again
ah [ __ ] he's good [ __ ] is good well I'm
kicking you BAM
how about how'd you like that I am ohad
you'd like that one
yes Garret Josh by Shaba nope no Gary
Rishabha oh how do you like me now
[ __ ]
O'Shea Gary you're scaring me
how the hell did he do that pretty easy
to beat honestly I'm just that good I
think and Furniture Fame Smith I heard
the whole thing you're expelled
oh yeah then tie me boy yes sir see you
there I think you know I think I may
have judged you too unfairly boy now
really yes a little rough around the
edges but you're a diamond boy
yeah I'm faster now take out the trash
would you Hopkins my pleasure so it was
you who took on this monstrous little
wretch was it yeah yep what a hero alone
a name well I had Russ with me though to
be honest sir I did have a lot of help
from some friends like this girl Zoey
she got expelled
because she complained about mr. Burton
hitting on Burton well he's fired
I hope he rots in hell he's a Wolski
good friend of mine never heard of him
yeah well he keeps quiet he's kind of
shy shy the boy must be a genius cool
great idea good now about that letter to
my mother what letter
ah they should just kiss now and that
word out what I mean I should just tug
and they've it all day finally
everything is sorted out more or less
I'm
I don't want to say we're going to live
happily ever after or anything like that
but life is certainly going to get
easier oh and he gets another girl
Jimmy's such a [ __ ] seriously he'll take
anyone I'm not saying she's bad but
literally he'll make out with anyone oh
oh my god missable barely see my III
that was a really great game that was
really cool I'm so glad I played it I
remember I played a DJ san andreas it's
way different so it's hard to compare
them but they are so similar at the same
time but I really enjoyed this a lot
ever met it made me remember how much I
enjoyed San Andreas so I think that was
pretty cool uh yeah it feels like a
classic almost because it's like I don't
know
and it's cool I could totally play it
again honestly and wouldn't mind that at
all but I want to take your boys for
watching this last night hope you
enjoyed it did you enjoy it yeah you did
thank you again so much for watching it
really means a lot to me that your
brothers watched its videos that I make
and I can play video games for you each
day and that makes me happy I'm serious
I'm not being sarcastic why would I be
seriously Liz Olson yeah um yeah great
this bread game great fun good laughter
lot of episodes probably the longest
series I have had running in a long time
honestly I think if I play this without
any cuts or without actually recording
everything I did probably be honestly
eighty parts instead probably even more
it's crazy because a lot of time went
from going from point A to point B or it
was like me getting the go card just
took me two hours
a lot of [ __ ] on you can do in the
game you could spend a lot more time in
the game as well with like playing games
and mini-games and whatever the [ __ ]
sometimes I felt like the game was
actually one entire big minigame but
yeah alright quick review quick review
uh story was interesting that was fun
kind of predictable but hey what's still
fun and really I don't know they didn't
take itself too seriously I liked that I
give it a 8 out of 10 and the music is
actually really chill it fits fits the
fits the game well it's nothing too too
amazing but it was memorable and fun so
I give that an 8 out of 10 as well uh
graphics well who gives a [ __ ] anyway
it's awesome that I can um rituals in
general I guess is better to say kind of
bad honestly it's a lot a lot of bad
things about that part give it a like a
[ __ ] 5 5 out of 10 but overall
enjoyment
I'd say 8.5 out of 10 great fun I'm
gonna wait until the credits and just
for the heck of it and then I'll see you
there is it over it is over
chapter 6 what the [ __ ] what what
during endless summer you can complete
all tasks that you may have missed I
think I did all of them I'm pretty sure
I did all of them the only one I didn't
do was the star over there but it's so
cool that you can keep [ __ ] around in
the game after you're finished yet
alright let's do it one final ride with
a diol she's here now that's kind of
cool I wonder what happened with Jeannie
though honestly and it was never really
resolved with Petey all right one final
ride with my dyrdek I pressed thanks for
watching like a beverage enjoy the sky
cumin bread today and I'll see you next
time to die there you gay I'm not gay
you're gay so you're gay
yep nothing wrong with a gay it's not
called being gay it's called being a
blast